the i-team brian is following another
federal investigation this time it's a
little bit closer to home
imagine finding a stash of mail-in
ballots right on the side of the road
it's a story you'll only see on 8 news
now tonight the i-team's david charns is
live in the northwest valley near
where cyclists actually found those
ballots and david your reporting has led
to a federal investigation right
denise we started asking questions after
this man told us
he found these ballots dumped right here
near lone mountain
and that's actually when the postal
service started asking
us questions sparking an investigation
inside the bike lane basically like
someone just going straight out the
window
an ordinary bike ride through the
northwest valley it seems really odd to
me
cruised to an unusual find for russell
layton
i just happened to see a bunch of mail
in the road
and it happened to be mail-in ballots
these unopened mail-in ballots there was
10 exactly
left in a ditch no letters no flyers
just
10 ballots 10 votes meant for someone at
home
it was a concern and it was also a
little bit confusing too
like it was it was mail-in ballots it
wasn't any other kind of mail
the ballots have addresses on ford
apache chieftain and hammer
layton says he found the ballots near
lone mountain that's about two miles
away
i looked at them and i noticed what they
were and
knew they were important and they needed
to be taken care of take care of them he
did
taking a selfie as he dropped them at a
mailbox
hopefully they got him inspectors with
the postal service tell the i-team it
appears a thief took the ballots from a
neighborhood delivery box
they're investigating the incident after
the i-team started asking questions
adding it's likely the thief was looking
for checks or credit cards and
tossed away the rest hopefully i did my
civic duty leighton says
if one of these ballots were his he'd
want someone to do the same
i knew i wouldn't want my ballots to be
on the side of the road i wanted to have
you know my ballot come to me in the
mail and thought it would be only fair
for them to get theirs
in the mail too
now elections officials tell us if you
do find someone else's ballot you should
always give them a call that number
702-455-vote
we also have that listed on our website
right now as for this investigation
inspectors say they were in this
neighborhood today watching surveillance
video
trying to figure this all out live near
lone mountain in the northwest valley
i'm david charns 8 news now